okay let's get started welcome and
welcome to the afternoon session after
lunch and actually it was hard to come
back to the field beautiful weather
outside hey we have exciting cooks and
first off is by unz and she will talk
about networks and thanks for coming
today I'm going to talk about learning
and generalization you or parametrize
neural networks kernels so as usual this
talk will be extremely simple and I hope
everyone can understand and enjoy the
topic so be extremely simple so let's
start as usual we also start with a bit
history of machine learning and so let's
start with the history of the practical
side of machine learning what happened
for the practical side of machine
learning I'm going to draw a graph that
is labeled by time and the power of the
model so on the ancient ham which is
about 20 years ago so people usually use
single day or learning models for
practical machine learning so well as is
single layer learning models they are
similar perceptions like linear
regression kernel method or linear
regression or feature mappings and you
can see the power is slightly is growing
but is saturated at some point and then
there is a phase two of practical
machine learning that boosted a graph a
little bit higher and what I call it's a
convex regularization phase in a
practical machine learning
what are these algorithms they are
essentially future mappings with convex
regulations for example you add a line
regularization for those who are you you
had nuclear norm regularization for the
quadratic feature matching or you add
PRC regularization for the powerful
architecture like sum of squares there
are all convex with regularization and
they are pretty powerful and then we
entered a phase three of practical
machine learning what happened in this
if we really jump into the multi-layer
learning model like couple years ago and
these are whether these models these are
the multi-layer perceptrons and usually
people call it deep learning and also
there are other non convex algorithms
that belong to this framework for
example base night for graphical models
and so so let's I send start with a
theoretical side of machine learning
what was a history of the radical side
of machine learning we can see like face
1 so we basically have the theory that
can catch up with the practice so we
understand most of the fundamental
question in this might in the single
layer learning model so we understand
sample complexity and computation
complexity and then we enter phase 2 we
even have a tighter connection between
theory and practice actually many of the
algorithms are actually inspired by
theoretical work there or region nation
is Theory instead of practice but the
IRA they run very well in practice so we
also have this graph now what happened
to phase 3 increasingly we are going
back in time so we suddenly go from here
to all the way down here and what
happened in theory so what is this apron
in the PAC learning cycle is actually
like the neural networks neural networks
with one neurons or neural network over
one dimension inputs so they are
extremely weak models and people in
order to study like macular learning
model people are forced was now go back
to he's go back to a time when the study
like for example a neural network that
can only learn linear functions so here
I'm only saying the power of the model
is very weak I'm not saying anything
about the types of the theory actually
there are a lot of very fundamental
theory in the day
for example what Tommy that's a
moderated so they are quite quite deep
but what I'm saying is just a power and
then what about besides this is like
twinning last layer of the neural net
which is your collects and actually
reduce to the conjugate kernel so it's
still below the line of kernel method
what about seesaw four C's will be more
interesting and people start to like
learner for example Matthew learner or
net who is kernel method like the
beautiful work by Jason so third modular
neural network using kernels but still
they are using kernels so he still below
the line of kernels and the most
recently there is approach called neural
tangent kernel that is newer Knight kind
sure Euler actually learn everything
that I learn about by polynomial kernels
so you getting closer to the threshold
of the kernel method but still we are
not going about that so still our theory
is below the age of the convex
regularization and what I should say
there is a phase three prime in the
theoretical machine learning which is
here yeah another dimension of this
graph what are these phase three prime
these are like learning neural net or
other models with very strong
distributional assumptions really just a
fury cold ocean and why isn't that a
different dimension is because it's
usually unrealistic in practice actually
so much learning community interest in
real world application always find this
setting very questionable and according
to row don't know Co punctual in your
nose if you try to tell them that your
your algorithm only work in these
furring work so clearly I don't want to
get punched so today I'm going to focus
on distribution for a park tag learning
instead of the distributional assumption
learning
and yunji so we work our saggy face the
neuro tangent colonel and we also cover
the e face that is beyond kernel
analysis for neural net that really jump
above the line of the kernel yes so on
part a you had learning one really I
don't how you learn one really using
kernel methods it's like you learn up to
absolute accuracy with like exponential
you more absolute many samples are
running hot I assume that the kernel
methods like means of the real
efficiency I know no it's like yeah it's
polynomial but if you're one if you
think of apps know as a constant like
Euler just a rail you have to cancel
accuracy then you can yeah right but I'm
saying the kernel method line you're
allowing those methods to run
exponential then accuracy relative
yeah I'm cheating a little bit so it's
usually polynomial but just for Ray
Lewis is expression for C moieties yeah
is polynomial yeah yeah
so also is in distribution for a pack
learning and so let's start with Senor a
tangent Colonel what is tangent colonel
and euro tangent Colonel to recover like
Mercer Colonel it's just a function over
a pair of input and which is a you know
product between two feature my teens I
can have arbitrary dimension you can use
it this is just this is Mercer Colonel
but usually when you talk about Colonel
metal we basically means is Colonel so
now given a smooth function that has a
parameter W and the input Heights so we
can expand this function that parameter
W zero which is super simple to just
write the Taylor expansion so I [ __ ] a
blue X is equal to the base one plus the
gradient am senior plus some
second-order term because the function
is smooth and now here is a tangent
kernel which is super simple given by
the future mapping of this function
which is just the gradient part of this
so you can see this is a future mapping
because it's only a function of X yes so
it's not a function of W because you put
W 0 inside so it's a multi-dimensional
function it's a feature making and this
is how the tangent kernel of this
function what is neuro tangent kernel is
very simple it's just a tangent kernel
so where f is just a neural network and
w0 is by default random initialization
that's what we called a neuro tangent
kernel
so here is the theorem about neuro
tangent Colonel so it's very very simple
so given convolution or fully connected
or even example to be Splash
normalization all their revenue or
network I have of tabloid where W is the
total parameter and eggs with ham
neurons per layer so given if the
network is trained on n distinct example
if the following conditions are
satisfied what is this opes condition so
you have our parameterization which is M
is bigger than polynomial into a number
of neuro and the number of layer so
there is oceans or permit rhodesia and O
in the polynomial and so P which is
proper initialization and typically is
just a Gaussian with universe of the
number of new room for air this is what
people use in practice and then there is
the small learning rate which is
learning rate is smaller than some one
where square root has a number of neuro
and if this old condition satisfied then
the following condition is true so
actually justifying that a blue star
efficiently with small training laws
there's a objective function can be
cross entropy out or any convex
objective lowest function so such that
it's a night work is just equal to is
starting for n plus the gradient so the
first order expansion plus a little of
one term okay
so this is a very simple theorem
just what it says adjusting if the oaths
condition is true so I still just
learned officially the neuro tangent
Colonel solution instead of learning a
funeral night he just learns the neuro
tangent Colonel solution this gradient
of whatever is the future macking and W
star minus W 0 is a linear regression so
greedy
so actually Geneva so if the Oaks
condition is foods and training neural
network it's just a proximity equal to
the linear regression or future mappings
given by the gradient of the random
initialization okay so that's a theorem
and this is really simple and also if
such foods and the problem is complex
and everything is extremely easy these
are like rather reasonable assumption
like over permutation property
initialization and smaller neural there
are no no crazy assumption and there is
no distributional assumption on the
training examples so the theorem is
super simple but there are kind of two
difficulties in the proof first of all
is rather activation and remember the
key intuition is like we can do a Taylor
expansion of the function so there is
like this term which is only true for
smooth function but for a dual function
which is not smooth you don't really get
this term so you don't have the
second-order term for function so this
makes a little bit more tricky and also
the I am bigger than polynomial ul so
you an considered smooth activation
functions this order of something is
usually the smoothness Hamzah Jesus but
the outer layer network is typically two
to zero smooth because you have out
layer and each pair is kind of like 1/2
because we have redwood that feels like
a half of the neuro
so typically like to to the our smoothie
instead of Holly all smooth so in order
to prove saturate via room you'll need
some non worst case bound these are like
to difficulties but still the theorem is
super simple and what is the intuition
of the proof again is super simple so
just have a truly random Network Texas
summation way I read off W items X I'm
nervous and what is proper visualization
the probably initial addition is a is
just Gaussian standard ocean and W is
zero proneural is like the ocean with
two to the N so the outfit at
initialization is order of one go to
cancel ization because each redwood the
size this one were route I'm and under
I'm of them but yes are random so you
cancel so ultra tight initialization is
older while and then neuro tangent
Colonel defined by the initialization is
nothing but in sorry I forgot a I had
but there should be some AI in front of
that your tangent kernel is second a
items this guy
so there is a simple observation which
is there exist a weight W star that is
very close to initialization so W star
has small trinny loss why this is true
because we alert the network you are not
going to learn something that cancels
with AI you learn something that aligns
with AI so don't get consolation
so if neural only needs to contribute
one where m and a is an order of 1 so
the total contribution is order of while
we override this output so your there
exists W star that is very close to
initialization so it has small twin your
host again this is super simple and
super intuitive like this means that
double star minus tableau 0 x axis in
the order of our ad but double zero x
axis in the order of our route and so
the fan pattern doesn't really change
for each training example and that means
the neural network stay close with MVP
and you can see that as M gets larger
and larger is getting closer and closer
to this is the intuition but Spacek is a
proof explicit Euler prophets in this
paper like learning over publish wise
neural network we are stochastic
gradient is on structured data in the
like a year ago this is super simple
what's the takeaway message the takeaway
message is just use the aux condition
hold like oops condition is over
parameterization proper initialization
small learning rate
if this condition hold and trinny neural
network is super simple like
trinny neural network bias VD is
equivalent to learning we is neuro
tangent kernel which is a convex
optimization problem you can derive all
the bounds you need as long as you have
to always condition so at this point
everyone is happy giving the smiling
face maybe except
for example him so yeah when I was
visiting I might here John asked me this
question if the neural network is really
in your tangent kernels and why do we
use neural networks in certain kernel
method at that time I mean I wasn't able
to answer the question so the widget
winter not very long but so I was only
be able to say something very big like
the neural network do better in practice
for example like me see far the best
neuron attack chief 99 percent accuracy
this is a state of the art you can
search it on the right it's a very crazy
network but you know 99 percent of
accuracy but Colonel Mercer County
achieved 85 using random dragon or
features or 77 using Newton Ares and DK
which is a neuro tangent kernel when the
result of M goes to infinity or only 65
if the M key K is not that large like
180 this is actually pretty big and it
takes like a day to train it but zero is
very very light but this is I practice
how it proves that neural network
actually do better the MGK in theory
and here I'm going to show a result in
this sighting so what you prove
something like the NGOs condition which
is you're still keeps a proper
initialization in the host and either
you change the over privatization to
something like semi or parametrization
or you're change a smaller new rates to
large turning rate equation twice a
three-layer right site and distribution
is really a popular concept class that
is more efficient and internal method
but only I really mean that we prove
both upper and lower bounds so we prove
an upper bound for for the further
further generalization error of the rest
night and we also prove a lower bound
for the generalization of any kernel
method so it's any kernel method just
either MGK or any pretty thing you can
come up with so the efficiency is like a
sample complexity running time or memory
okay so this is what we are going to
show now what is a learning network is
just a three layer night right night
with value activation which is very
simple you have inputs internal beginner
and value and identity mappings that
only jumps one nonlinear layer so jumped
I didn't even jump through while loop
it's very simple it's a single ski for
ice night
okay or if you want to write it in
mathematical formula you just look like
this what is a concept class the concept
class is just a three-layer right Knight
who is using all their smooth activation
a concept class I mean like the target
function you want to learn something
like this like HX is equal to some F X
plus alpha times G of F X where alpha is
something small I don't really mean
little of one or some small constant so
what does it mean it just means that you
have a base signal that is very simple
and this large and they don't have a
composite signal that is small but it's
hard because it's composition and you
can visualize it like this formula like
F is this simple formulas and there is
actually an arrow in the formula Kai was
spotted 16 divided by 4 is equal to 3 as
well because the learner used that
formula is a calculation of G is
actually also wrong yeah but so you can
see that the base formulas are very
simple and by the form a large
population and you can use this base
formula together into a composite
formula like that we has one of them but
it's a it's difficult some learning
tasks like this but it's a little bit
different because now the to function at
Kaiser so is kinda like you blurred
these two thing into one function what
is F F is K output K dimension out whose
function that is equal to F given by F 1
up to FK and each of F J is just some
some neural network with smooth
activation and we don't waste our other
one and the G is also the same it's just
on your night
well it's a complexity measure of this
function so for any of this activation
function where input is 1 1 and the
weight is also norm 1 and Phi like
infinite order smooth you can do the
Taylor expansion and you can define the
complexity of an activation function
which is very simple just a summation of
the absolute value of the coefficient
Francis it's basically just as as
ellipses so CIF is just equal to the
summation of the activations for D so
it's a very simple measure it's super
simple
ok so why do we have this measure
because first of all if the activation
function is crazy like a jumpsuit of
pros you cannot learn it and also this
is the sample complexity or tum
comparison to verify using kernel method
actually using polynomial kernels
ok so these are the sample complex so
basically what you'll keep in mind these
are the complexity to learn the function
using kernels to learn either hyper G
even training sample X or X prime okay
so now we have the sorry it's just all
the things that can be written in age
with complexity of F and G are bounded
by the following measure bounded by some
black counsel some value C that C is the
complexity of your concept class
is like one dimensional function yes sir
so I've I've Jason aura is a summation
of activation function of the inner
product it's like a to learn your - yeah
yeah is some polynomial smooth
activation so G's the function G is also
a two layers in by G composed with F is
really
so this is like concept class as you are
going to learn and actually you can do
improper learning you can do agnostic
learning you can learn it with Jairo
there's no problem
so what is a learning algorithm so the
last we are going to use the eye out to
loss and the night worse so remember to
break the MGK regime we are going to
change the over parametrization or
change the learning rate so how do we
change our parametrization we just rip
hermit right we buy some we plant some
say which is full rank and their
training algorithm is just SPD with
small learning rate times and there is
no regularization at all there's no way
DK or anything that regularize the
capacity of the algorithm which is
actually starting or alternatively we
can change smaller near a to larger any
rate prison ways just exist so you have
a very detail on each parameter and then
you have a gradient and a notice are
very large ways we use artificial in
ways like the ocean that was covariance
is the covariance of the input to the
neural so for example VI is a input this
value of W thumbtack so you'll have
these covariance or WI the coherences
accessible so you can either do that or
a meter or you can do that algorithms
they can both give you the result
so this is actually the Gaussian
approximation of the ICT types of waste
because if you have like a finite budget
covariance of the actual universe is
approximately equal to that not really
so it's not a rigorous statement and
intuitively the eventually the rail you
of WX will align with a through the
signal it has value of W times I so
learning is a learned by it will just
have a very big imagine area and there
is no other dominant impression so this
is actually there it will color to a a
transpose so go back to the first case
there is no fundamental difference
between the two
okay so now we are happy to state our
theorem and what is the theorem so the
serum just says given any distribution
of X on the unit pole this really nice
will are loads of fun nurse concept
class that is written in this formula up
to generalization our parable alpha
square means that your H nu are deeper
by some alpha square factor and there's
a following conditions first opt out the
number of neuro is ICG of f complexity
of G and 1 where alpha and the sample
complexity is complexity of F plus
complexity of gene by the heart out to
the power 4 which are all super standard
the running time is polynomial in the
complexity there are all super standard
so it's nothing hard in the theorem but
what's what's interesting is just it
only depends on the individual
complexity of gia knife and it doesn't
depend on the complexity of the
composite function and the lower bound
however with what we can prove this over
some distribution of X and obviously the
over bound has to be for some
distribution because if the distribution
is just a single tintin there is there
is no lower bound so for some
distribution of x on the unit ball and
for some class of functions like G and H
any kernel method its alert the concept
function H up to generalization error
d2o of alpha remember alpha is some
small value must use sample complexity
that depends on the complexity of the
composite function G of H P alive ok so
the difference is when you're on that
list that complexity either just G and F
and G and what's kernel loads of
complexities the complexity of the
composite function which is
see
so this is a theorem and it's super
simple there is nothing yeah it's going
to be infinite yeah so what what do I
mean by kernel method the kernel method
is like you are define any kernel like
even by the automatic and you'll predict
the output function using the feature
matching times the summation of your
training example usually the test
surveys are twinned over the training
samples but this way in this result it
doesn't matter what how do you obtain
this way you can use crazy algorithm
like even so VMP not equal to MV but as
long as you obtain some kernel solution
like this then you are going to suffer a
high generalization error okay yes so
you seem to indicate that the fact that
any kernel method fails is strong but I
kind of feel like then something must be
wrong with the distributional assumption
because take C far I know there exists a
kernel that works well it's just I take
C far 10.1 are very similar dataset oh
yeah yeah exactly so yeah this is like
for some class of function which means
that it has to work well for all the
functions in this class so if you're a
CFR is like there exists one function or
cross there exists one kernel but if I
change C far to like a class of images
for a class of distribution where they
yeah or the class of class of images
like or the class of labeling functions
something like the class of these
functions it's not a single function but
a class of function so everything in the
class
for alpha and these classes I mean is it
their fixed prices Virginia or so
basically it's an upper bound calls for
our file that is smaller the lower bound
is for any are no it speaks the class
and for any ARPA yeah so your first fix
PMF then you or perhaps we are about
yeah yeah I just wanted to learn a
baseline so if I just predict F oh
thanks what is generalization error is
harfa because yeah it's are fast so it's
this below both of the line yeah so it's
this is alpha square so you'll have two
large e yeah what if you alternate a few
times you learn up just by using the
output and then alternating a few times
yes that's essentially like what the
neural net - yeah if you just cannot do
it in one shot that kernel sue
okay so to answer his question in some
cases a combat complexity of G and F can
be much much larger than the individual
complexity of G&I there are infinite
larger for example when F is equal to
square root D times W times X where W is
normal axis a random unit vector in
dimension D and then because W times D
is typically in the order of our buddies
or athlete so truth of F is typically in
the order of 1 in the order of 1 so it's
a good function then the complexity of F
is nothing but square root D because
this you know the weight coefficient
okay and then G is just a one
dimensional function which is equal to Z
to the power of 10 and then the
complexity of G is just order of 1
because the coefficient is 1 and the
degree is bouncing but the G conversate
with F is just his actually square root
D to the power of 10 times W of X to the
power of 10 so the complexity of G and a
composite complexities e to the power of
5 because these are all unit and then
this is activation function this is a
coefficient which is d to the power of
10 so it's e to the 5
and then the theorem just says the
wrestler's is like square rudi of the
base function plus alpha times the
square root of base function to the
power of 10 up to accuracy alpha square
remember these things in the order of 1
so you have to learn like for example
this part a little bit better and then
using like D divided by poly our family
samples for any alpha that is little 1
and since the lower bound says that
kernel mass of maseo's at least e to the
10 samples for largest function up to
accuracy Leto of Arva so as long as
these try to alert the degree 10 part
he just had to use e to the Tang example
here are you saying this those
essentially these are like the bad
Costas yeah yeah the you know paper we
actually use a different contraction but
this one also work
right so we basically we probably have
this following picture we all have rice
night you can have a smallest set of
example and then the learning succeed
but if you use kernel method so you use
a large sample pool but the kernel
messes you so just the separation
actually proved put us in here
that lob up I miss above the layouts or
no
okay so there are some extension of this
theorem for example you can be extent to
feature mappings instead of kernels just
remember the kernel algorithm looks like
this so you'll have to predict using
this linear combination but what if I
use an arbitrary tableau that is not in
this file
so here is the theorem saying that were
linear for linear equation over feature
mapping with any regularization so the
in your regression mask use number of
features that are in these guitars combo
set complexity so you can use very few
samples for example maybe you can write
a sum of square architecture that is
solve the problem very efficiently just
remember sum of square is nothing but
each linear regression or feature
mapping with sighs deeply with PSTA
constraint and if you have your sum of
square to solve it very efficiently but
you cannot solve it you know a very
small running time so you have to use a
lot of these feature markings and decide
which one
yes what's wrong with just using one
rail you to achieve your separation with
epsilon being small learning the
gradient methods but my Redwoods us
so first of our four four varieties you
can only like there are two sightings of
four seconds you are in the units of
here so the hidden weights are normal
and axis nor y-axis so input is more one
you want to learn it up to have some air
arrow so you'll run into an
exponentially more absolute that you can
also do that using kernels and there are
other cycling where you have
distributional assumption which is an
input discussion and then you color the
red activation but as I said our lower
one is distribution freeze their
gradient methods that are learning in
polynomial time
Absalon and the that's for that's
mystery Bill Shankly we saw distributed
out this actually and it's actually hard
but it's not hard for example if you
just assume it oh yeah yeah so Horace I
think is also you now can also say so
renovate the theorem is stated in like
that is grading methods but maybe
splitting hairs but it's not an
ingredient
reasonable here on their neural nets and
they're kind of somewhat standard Nero
there right so here I understand
correctly the learning method this is
grading descent and it
nine yeah we're as good learn the rivers
you be ready to be sent in somebody who
doesn't so basically it's a running time
is slow because you'll need to go
through all the features so for
determining trying picking the width and
then just passes through we didn't try
this I think yeah but we try to really a
result the right snack time we got going
to show something and the other question
is that so the way you're able to not
pay for the composition in the
generalization bound is by first
learning as many GS you said see Bijou
did you also try to study more general
class two functions that you could did
you like to try to understand general
settings
this is sort of two or three days
learning even and the always get to not
the competition but the summation of yet
but you'll have to use some
distributional assumptions and we can't
push the result to our lair so you have
to do a face of the learn resettle to
resolve distribution or something that's
the to Larry's already mutation if you
use three-phase then we kind of value if
you have distribution or something you
can push it so because also extends its
upper bound to convolution eyes such as
these and you can also expand the
extends the upper bound to order of
alpha square two like essentially zero
with some distribution of our subjects
are awesome extensions so what is the
intuition behind the result like people
have already figured out the right side
is doing implicit hierarchical learning
which is the first loris I've using like
MDK and then theis have to the second
layer of the network and energy using
means a second layer and DK so it's a
the complexity is the ngpa complexity
which is called as the O'Laughlin
combated LP just look like C's which is
super simple but kernel methods is by
short learning so healers 305 from
scratch as if there is no bass signal
effects which is very unique vision no
matter how cleverly you Raisa kernel you
just cannot really use the information
because it's coalesce and
so the learning is implicit hierarchical
because the to learn to two layers are
twin simultaneously and there is no
change of the learning rate so don't
really trim the first layer and then
between the second layer and then there
is no regularization of the first day or
so and also there's no regularization on
the first on the second layer so the
right side has to act really distribute
the learning process automatically
there's no outer force that force it to
first thereafter merge it's automatic
they are twin together okay so here is
the higher level intuition so as people
have figure out this really simple you
just learn F using ng k up to accuracy
alpha and then you will feel like I've
plus minus alpha to the second layer of
G and then you alergy how to accuracy
alpha so your total accuracy is alpha
square because T huzzah so if you use
these conclusions and hope you'll just
get this like everything is wrong why
because the total accuracy is actually
our fastest at least only alert in the
first year up to accuracy alpha so when
you alert the second layer you actually
helps the first layer to correct the
error of X you cannot do it by first
learning happens earlier G so you'll
have to use the G to help the first
layer to learn have more accurate okay
so it's important that the both they are
trained together is intuition of the
result and is also super simple and this
is essentially the proof the proof is
very simple and everything I just said
so the key message is the both layers
are still individual and ek but after
learning the first layer actually he is
some vital input to the ng help the
second layer this is a learning process
that allows it to goes beyond and DK
it's like an implicit hierarchy coder is
alpha inversely polynomial and
complexity of F no no it only depends on
the complexity of P is less than like
powers
so here is the experiment that we want
to say that the serum is good but what
if we use reona or nighttime create
using some arbitrary learning rate and
whatever so we designed this function H
which is equal to beta times Alpha X
plus alpha times G of X so harfa is 0.3
and beta times 1 and I feel some
function that has 8 output and G is some
function like a degree or parity as this
is our two example and I axis like a
uniform sample from that and what we try
is like 100 examples and we very
different I have different number of
hidden Europe so can see this is a 3
right side like what we prove it's
always below this and this is a baseline
where you'll learn F but you'll learn
nothing about G and the thriller network
actually go below it a little bit but
definitely not has fooled us right now
and then you have MGK or Trini last
layer they're all above who cannot learn
that ok and also the alpha is small it's
necessary so we which was our Phi equal
to 0.3 and we change beta so you can see
these two lines they are like beta is
0.4 beta is 0 so beta is facing the
coefficient of basic no you can see when
the coefficient of the base signal is
too small you can learn nothing so you
cannot learn all you can just lower half
so you have to have a very large base
signal which means that or assumption is
kind of necessary that are very high
signal is larger than the composition is
not a hard difficult proof
and there is a more interesting
experiment that we want to verify origin
through Asia that is we actually feed
battery inputs to MGK instead of
changing the Fisher mapping so remember
right away something like a visual
mapping that is equal to the indicator
times a linear of the ways so we just
changed a redwood who really decompose a
railroad hue indicator to a future
Magnum and the neutrons are different
wait so this W 1 and W 2 so we need to
replace an indicator by indicator yota
because we want to keep the function to
be ellipses during the training table
you one space I random visualization so
your future marketing is always random
you only use random feature matching so
it's always ng k and only the linear
thing is print everywhere is in jpg and
so it does not learn a better feature
mapping but feed better include visual
mapping it's basically it's not a formal
statement
so our eyesight that is 8 times wide for
the original network that is Raul yoga
she was important ninety-five point five
five five for the modify network is very
close now you are see 400 is still
relatively close just down by one point
whatever percent but definitely much
much better than kernel so this is a
deep linear network no it's not deep
linear you have this you change our
value by this one we all have the
indicator but all your trains w-2 you
don't because I freeze the activation
and only
so it's linear network means product of
parameters yeah yeah yeah it's really a
linear that yeah it's a linear in our
not a linear function yeah it's a linear
night huh yes it's really a linear
network yeah
so you and for this linear network you
can do that yeah so I see you really you
really what all you need is feed battery
input to the future magic ah sorry it's
not really linear what I say it's wrong
so the activation actually change
because you are your your knife Slayer
actually feels different X with this so
it change this one and it's not really
at least yeah yeah sorry yeah so just a
summary so in this hawk what you show is
Iike we have under oops condition which
is this poor family friends even poverty
neutralization is small learning rate
it's a neural network oh so your neural
network is NGK and neural network goes
beyond and Quique where some conditions
are broken for example and then there
are more work for example you'll break
the small learning rate to a scheduled
learning rate this is a new paper that I
talked at some places know that says if
you use scheduled learning rate instead
of smaller rates and you'll learn
something with spider generalizations
NGK it's also provable lower and upper
bound and also your change
initializations and you have a railway
network this lower parameter is where we
work and there are some distribution
okay so there's some future direction
for example neural net is provided by
there's any kernel method so we have
show here but what about any convex up
rhythm for example Calley show this line
here so I believe if you can show
something here then we are really
entering the deep learning region but
now we are not really close to that so
this is a very important future
direction because how I learn you're in
my report like some of swears
[Applause]
and yet work no I mean convex
optimization instead of convex algorithm
so you'll have to use the optimization
instead of any arbitrary algorithm for
example sum of square is like a linear
regression or visual mapping which we
actually drew out because we go out
linear regression over feature Matthews
in general the sample complexity that we
brought is actually the running time so
you have to use a lot of features you
may reduce the sample composite it's NIM
poly yeah but it's some of our algorithm
instead of sum of square optimization so
yeah we can talk about that later
yeah
[Applause]
so our our speaker now the last speaker
today is honey and shoot us both sites